kubernetes a tool for managing and
automating containerized workloads in
the cloud
imagine you have an orchestra think of
each individual musician as a docker
container
to create beautiful music we need a
conductor to manage the musicians and
set the tempo
now imagine the conductor as kubernetes
and the orchestra as an app like
robinhood when the markets are closed an
app like robinhood
isn't doing much but when they open it
needs to fulfill millions of trades for
overpriced stocks like tesla and shopify
kubernetes is the tool that orchestrates
the infrastructure to handle the
changing workload it can scale
containers across multiple
machines and if one fails it knows how
to replace it with a new one a system
deployed on kubernetes is known as a
cluster
the brain of the operation is known as
the control plane it exposes an api
server that can handle both internal and
external requests to manage the cluster
it also contains its own key value
database called
etcd used to store important information
about running the cluster
what it's managing is one or more worker
machines called nodes
when you hear node think of a machine
each node is running something called a
cubelet
which is a tiny application that runs on
the machine to communicate back with the
main control plane mother ship
inside of each node we have multiple
pods which is the smallest deployable
unit in kubernetes
when you hear pod think of a pot of
whales or containers running together
as the workload increases kubernetes can
automatically scale horizontally by
adding more nodes to the cluster
in the process it takes care of
complicated things like networking
secret management persistent storage and
so on
it's designed for high availability and
one way it achieves that is by
maintaining a replica set which is just
a set of running pods or containers
ready to go
at any given time as a developer you
define objects in yaml that describe the
desired state of your cluster
for example we might have an nginx
deployment that has a replica set with
three pods
in the spec field we can define exactly
how it should behave like its containers
volumes ports and so on you can then
take this configuration and use it to
provision and scale containers
automatically and ensure that they're
always up and running and healthy
this has been kubernetes in 100 seconds
like and subscribe for more and you can
support my work by sponsoring me on
github or by becoming a pro member at
fireship io for even more content
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one